اعزاز في حلب بينضموا الى حمزه العبد الله
المدير التنفيذي للهيئه العالميه للاغاثه
وتنميه مرحبا بك في الهمزه عبد الله قيل
بان عمليه انقاذ
توقفت الان يتم فقط التركيز على انتشال
الجثث ما هي اولويات عملكم الان
بطبيعه الحال يعني بعد مضيء اضطرابه الخمس
ايام او تجاوزنا الى اليوم السادس
باتت امال ايجاد ناجين تحت الانقاب يعني
جدا محدوده في سوريا مع كل اسف كان هناك
تباطؤ من دعم الموجود باتجاه جهود الانسان
مما ادى الى فقدان كثير من الالوان
الساعات القادمه والايام القادمه تكشف عن
اعداد ضحايا كسر جراء هذا التاخر الذي حصل
وبعض
الدعم الذي اتجه يعني لجهود الانقاذ
ولجهود فرق الدفاع المدني الدفاع المدني
السوري عمل بجهود جدا محدوده وبامكانيات
محدوده ضمن المتوفر لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
ولكن الان مع كل اسف الان نبدا
بمرحله انتشار الجثث ويعني
تقولون ان هناك تباطؤ في الاستجابه
لمناشدات الانقاذ داخل سوريا
من يتحمل المسؤوليه هنا
حقيقه من يتحمل مسؤوليه ذلك والمجتمع
الدولي والدول الفاعله عالميا يعني هناك
وكذلك لبنان لا يعني لا مسؤوليه كل الدول
التي كانت تستطيع بامكانها ان تقدم في
كوارث كالزلازل الساعات الاولى بعد وقوع
الكارثه هي ساعات مصيريه ومفصليه في انقاذ
حياه الكثيرين ضمن سوريا وضمن الامكانيات
التي كانت متاحه تم العمل بضمن امكانيات
الدفاع المدني السوري وبجهود متطوعين من
المنظمات المحليه ذلك لم يكن كافي ولا
اشدنا مرارا وتكرارا يعني دعم
وتقديم المساعده في هذا المجال لان المجال
الاساسي الذي كان خلال الساعات الماضيه
منذ وقوع الزلزال الى اليوم كانت الاولويه
هي اولويه الانقاذ اليوم الاولويات اختلفت
هناك اول
الجرحى اولويات الايواء وايجاد العالميه
للاضافه والتنميه انتم في الهيئه العالميه
للغاثه والتانيه ماذا فعلتم
نحن منذ اللحظه الاولى كنا نقدم الغذاء
ونقدم الدواء ونقدم
الماوى ضمن الامكانيات المتاحه
واعود واكرر ضبط الامكانيات المتاحه لانه
في حاله الشمال السوري الى اليوم المعابر
التجاريه مغلقه بشكل تام المعامل
الانسانيه فتحت جزئيا ولكن الى الان
ومساعدات جدا محدوده يعني على مستوى
الايواء نحن نبحث عن الصيام منذ لحظه وقوع
الزلزال الى هذا اليوم الخيام جدا محدوده
والحدود مغلقه لذلك نحن نعمل في ظروف جدا
غايه في التعقيد وفي الصعوبه وبشحه
امكانيات حتى في السوق المحلي الذي نستطيع
منه توفير مواد اغاثيه همزه الاغافيه داخل
سوريا عملت بما تستطيع ولكن الامكانيات
جدا ده وامكانيات تكاد تكون معدومه هذا
المشكله هنا في عدم الحصول على امكانيات
على عدم الحصول على المستلزمات والمتطلبات
التي انتم تبحثون عنها وربما متوفره في
الخارج وتجدون صعوبه في ادخالها ام ان
هناك ربما تجاهل او تهاون في توفير هذه
الامكانيات من الجهات التي كنتم تعاونون
عليها
حقيقه الامرين يعني هناك تهاون كبير وهناك
تخاذل اذا صح التعبير وليس تهاون هناك
تخادل باتجاه
المسانده
للشمال السوري اليوم الشمال السوري
يعاقب بالشمال السوري يعني يهمل اليوم ال
ال حقيقه
يعني الاف العوائل لا تجد ماوى لها هي في
ظل هذه الظروف الجويه القاسيه البرد درجات
الحراره المتدنيه الى ما تحت الصفر
كان بالامكان الدول ان تعمل شيء كان
بامكانه مؤسسات الدوليه ان تتحرك مبكرا ان
تتحرك مع الساعات الاولى ولكن مع الاسف
الى النهضه لا تزال
سيد سيد حمزه اين المشكله اين المشكله
بالتحديد يعني هل هو تخاذل مقصود انت لعدم
تقدير حجم الماساه في البدايه ام تخادل
لضغوط ما من جهه ما لكي لا تدخل المساعدات
الى الشمال السوري
يعني لنكن صريحين ما كان في
السياق السوري هو هذا استمر هو التسييس
الملف الانساني بشكل كبير
من سقطوا جراء زلزال من ضحايا وجرحهم من
المدنيين هم من
البشر الذين من حقهم ان يحصلوا على
المساعده تم توجيه كثير من المساعدات
باتجاه مناطق النظام وتم اهمال الشمال
السوري بالرغم من ان الشمال هو الاكبر
تضررا والاكثر تضررا من جراء الزلزال يعني
في مناطق كجنديرس تدمرت احياء ومناطق فيها
بشكل كامل
باعزاز بسلقين هذه مناطق كانت تحتاج ولا
تزال تحتاج يعني لا تزال الى هذه اللحظه
تحتاج حلول ايواء ولا كما ذكرت لا توجد
حتى الخيام بداخل سوريا هناك تسييس بالملف
السوري بشكل كبير وتسميس بالمدنيين ضمن
الشمال السوري
المساعدات مرتبطه باجندا وبمكاسب تحصل
عليها اطراف هنا وهناك ودول هنا وهناك على
حساب حياه المدنيين هذا حدث في كوارث
سابقه وفي حتى نزوحات سابقه كبيره واليوم
يتكرر في كارثه طبيعيه كنا نتوقع ان يتم
تنحيه كل هذه الحسابات جانبا ويتم النظر
الى الحاله الانسانيه ولكن مع كل اسف هذا
لم يحدث
الايام القادمه ستكشف كميه الضحايا الذين
انهم لا يزال تحت الانقاب الارقام المعننه
هي ارقام جدا بسيطه مما تم الوصول اليه
بين ضحايا بما تم الوصول اليه من مواقع
ضمن الامكانيات المتاحه ولكن هناك اضعاف
هذه الارقام فيها لا تزال
ولا تزال غير مرئيه يعني شكرا
السوري ضمن الامكانيات
الموجوده هو يستغيث حتى في الساعات
القادمه لان من اصيبوا ان لم تتوفر لهم
رعايه طبيه كافيه سيكون
حمزه والص
غار الذين لم
خيارات ماوى في ظل درجات التجمد سيكونون
مهددين ان يكونوا ضمن الضحايا
لا تزال مستمره نحتاج حقيقه التفاته الى
الشمال السوري ومعاناته بشكل عاجل
وهذا يتحمل مسؤوليته كل الدول سواء كانت
الدول العربيه او الانسانيه او المصطبه
عبد الله المدير التنفيذي الهيئه العالميه
للاغاثه وتنميه مدينه ازات فيري في حاله
شكرا